what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
duty lou um never heard of him featuring
push iced bodies before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified
of my daily videos all right let's
let's go all right what's the word
that [ __ ] goes too crazy
[Music]
okay so when he says catch a body um
he's talking about hooking up with a
female
so he wants to catch a body he wants to
hook up with a pretty girl
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's saying um that he is with
his friends that are killers that means
they're not afraid to shoot they will
shoot you
on top of that he hangs out with crips
now that's
if you didn't know that's a gang it up
with my amigos i was hustling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he says there's no such thing
there there ain't no sorry something
like that
he's just saying there's no such thing
as sorry um actions speak louder
than words
[Music]
he was selling pounds in the trenches so
he was selling
um pounds what does that mean
i don't know some sort of maybe like
contraband in the trenches so we stand
like in the hood
and he was helping everyone else he was
giving people money
why does this kid have that much cash
why is nobody
asking asking the tough questions
[Music]
what free poo
scheisties poo sheisty in jail or
something what is going on with poo
sheisty
um that was a fun little song
i'll give it a four out of five pretty
cool song
um talking about hooking up with girls
um some guns
you know drugs yeah that's pretty much
it
don't forget guys subscribe to the
channel help a girl out
you already know um while you're at it
follow my instagram
justpearlythings but with the z i'll
talk to you guys next